foreign
[Music]
guys
welcome hey it's the karaoke after party
can't believe we're here we're doing it
this is crazy how does my voice sound it
sounds like it's right in front of me
hey guys welcome to the Kelly after
party man what a crazy day that was a
question we're just waiting for a few
people to come in here right now and so
we're gonna I don't know about you but
after today I could use a cocktail let's
do it I mean seriously we can't talk
about today's show yet but it's probably
one of the craziest shows we've done in
Four Seasons so be tuned get ready for
this we did so much music
so what are we gonna have
for a cocktail yeah is it a Negroni yeah
you know what I love Negroni I may have
pre-made a little bit at home for you
Jason is uh quite The Connoisseur when
it comes to negronis
uh what do you have here a round ice
round ice cubes I'm using small ones so
we can get more Negroni I like that more
Negroni equals more fun check this out
we're so excited that you guys are here
send your questions over it's gonna be a
wild time and we're gonna Deep dive into
all types of stuff and uh oh is it time
it's not time yet we need to garnish it
but we're just waiting for some people
to come in here yeah we've got an
audience already in the room we have our
executive producer here we have my right
hand
we have my right hand gal Rachel here
and Emily schmimly and Alicia
but let's garnish this right uh yeah
yeah how do we do this well apparently
our uh producer Dandy Andy is from
Australia and they do them differently
there this this is not how you garnish
an agroni we're gonna get a nice thick
cut out of this
we have a couple names for our producer
Andy and maybe we should take a little
poll we could be he's from Australia
okay so he could be Aussie Osborne
oh that's pretty good what about Dr Ozzy
that's enough for me what about producer
Dandy Andy
what about Andy Down Under
all right I'm like do I have no people
here to start this thing let's go this
was supposed to be talking about Kelly
Okies I mean welcome to the karaoke
after party this is something I actually
went to Alex to about a year ago for
three years now what do we do after the
final episode of every week Jocko and I
head down to the bar
have some drinks and we talked to four
minutes and it's impossible not to talk
about work there's so much music to do
we're so excited so we just usually sit
there and talk for hours about Kelly
okay it's about work about the music one
of the first times we actually went to
have drinks after a show I started
talking to you about work and you said
can we just not talk about work yeah
it's impossible and then we like timed
it and I think we made it like 20
minutes 15 minutes and then it was like
what about that one song like did I play
that right so we thought it'd be cool
instead of just us sitting at the bar
talking about music ourselves we want to
invite all of you to come join us so
this is either going to go one of two
ways it's either going to be us talking
by ourselves or we need you guys to
interact and please send us some
questions because we want to talk about
what you want to talk about and as a
matter of fact we have NBC standards and
practices waiting in the door to take us
off the air as soon as we mess up so
don't leave us our own devices to talk
please and we forgot to say Cheers
Cheers Cheers
cheers cheers oh yeah that's good
so what we want to do man we get I don't
know about you Jocko well you're not on
social media that much not that much bro
I've been called a lurker I'm all over
the place I love seeing what we have the
best fan community at least you're not a
leader yeah I'm not a leader I'm a
Leicester but they actually you guys
give us so many ideas that we've
incorporated into tour and on the show
and it just it makes us look good how is
that does that make it too strong that's
good and it is strong which makes it
good yeah well that's what's good so I
instead of just answering all these
things and we've done interviews and
we've talked about it in text I thought
it'd be great to just show you what we
do
um putting together Kelly okay so we
want to show you behind the scenes and
the exciting thing is is that we're
going to get into licensing you guys
have so many questions about licensing
well we have gotten special permission
to break down in detail one song from
the last couple of weeks that we've done
yeah and it's gonna be a big one so
without further Ado welcome to the Kelly
after party
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh sorry oh man poor form here sorry hey
hopefully you guys are leaving questions
for us in the comments Emily's over
there reading I think she's got her
reading glasses on and hopefully there's
going to be some information for us
coming soon I I also have been doing a
poll for Emily's nicknames and and I
think I've just settled on one that's
great which is M Night sham uh Margarita
M Night Margarita I almost said M Night
Shyamalan
ruin the whole thing
all right that's great
what do we man so where we tape out of
order so like I said we just finished an
episode that you're not going to see
until the end of the month uh but over
the last couple of weeks the one today
though that's wild you have no idea like
usually in a in a single episode we do
21 22 cues of Music uh Rachel how many
we do today
47 pieces of music today does anybody
know when this one airs Mr Osborne do
you know the 30th November of November
okay thank you tune in on the 30th of
November thank you producer it's wild so
for the last couple weeks what we did
our Halloween show that was wild
um it was I mean the effects were really
fun I'm glad we don't I'm glad I don't
work in sci-fi or horror the amount of
makeup it took to do that was crazy so
they had uh they had me in the zombie
outfit as as you know and uh they had to
put me first in like a onesie and then
they put me in like an I think it was
being retired after this episode but I
think they said that but but it was
literally like a a zombie outfit made of
rubber that was deteriorate
deteriorating so it was like sticky yeah
and so Jason has a picture of it um but
like four people were pulling this skin
tight rubber suit onto me but they all
had to wear gloves because it was
leaving the sticky residue all over
their hands which as you might guess was
all over my guitar I couldn't get out
from under my fingernails and then we
start filming and it's you know a long
episode
and I can't stop sweating yeah I noticed
that was pretty gross brutal but you
know we're here to talk about music not
your sweaty costumes so I'm just curious
I didn't I didn't think about it until I
saw the video you had like long claws on
right yeah so no uh like zombie hands so
were you actually playing guitar yeah
really okay how'd you do that I forget
okay
it was pretty amazing uh we did the Sam
Smith duet that was awesome uh yeah that
was great dude I was impressed he is
such an awesome singer and they're
really tall too yeah I mean yeah but he
sounded amazing it was a really cool
thing uh we had Jonathan Majors we had
Tim Allen on so it's been just do you do
push-ups like that like Jonathan Majors
do I look like I do push-ups like
Jonathan majors
here let's lift question
all right number two okay thank goodness
they're saving us there's actually a
question so that we can stop rambling
what do we have Emily schmel no M nights
margarita
wow so so Rachel wants to know how long
does it take to do the Kelly okay from
choosing the song to the final
performance
um
that's a long what is this a two-hour
live stream uh yeah so producer Dandy
Andy wants me to wrap this one up fast
just talk really fast yeah uh do that
really well do the do your Kelly
impression my what Kelly impression I
don't have a Kelly impression no I just
mean because she speaks fast does she I
think so okay cool
hey Kelly
um hey Kelly yeah we uh once the song is
chosen we get requests from audience
members from Twitter Instagram staff
members
um wives uh friends I mean we're
constantly getting and speaking of this
is an official place to put in some
karaoke requests so if you have any
requests you want to hear drop them in
the comments I promise you we look at
them because we have we've done already
what 700 and we have we just got renewed
for two more seasons so we have a lot
more Keller gets to go
that was a good tone
okay we need a we need a drinking sound
effect
um so so we have a collection of songs
that you guys have requested and then
they we have to go out to clearance
because we can't perform a song on video
unless the songwriters so that's an
interesting thing a lot of people think
that the artist approves a song so if we
want to cover
um
I don't know a Taylor Swift song it has
to be the writer that approves it so if
Taylor co-wrote with
who's the guy she always her producer
come do some music yeah Max Martin Jack
Antonoff whatever every writer has to
approve it and we have to wait for that
I have a question actually does the
artist have to approve if they didn't
write it no only other songwriters have
to approve that's the only person has to
do interesting so then once we have that
we arrange the song I have to take
somebody's piece of art something
they've worked their career to do and I
have to condense it down to one and a
half minutes so I have don't need that
section I have butchered some of the
biggest Classics of all time and uh
We've you know and people tell me about
that yes sorry I couldn't work in the
sax solo to Careless Whisper fish so
um and then once we arrange it Jesse
comes in here in my office by the way
this is actually my office this is not a
set
um we call this Jason's Vibe room yeah
it's the vibe room so this is this is
where it all happens
um Jesse comes in right here and we
record vocal for Kelly to learn and the
band rehearses the song uh we rehearse
one day a week we have a few hours for
her six songs eight hours to learn all
of our bumpers all of our cues all over
things plus the six songs for the week
and then I'd make a little mix for Kelly
we send it out to lighting into video
and everybody does their their parts
Kelly gets the song the morning of the
show listens to it in glam
and we get maybe one run through on
stage and then we do it so no joke
she doesn't hear it until the morning of
in the Glam room where she's getting her
hair and makeup done and then she shows
up on stage and I can't I can't say F
words I don't think so no let me ask NBC
standards and practices out in the
hallway she ducking nope they're saying
no she ducking kills it it's wild it's
awesome so so speaking of let's dive
into a few Kelly Okies um one of the
ones I wanted to talk about was
California Dreaming it's actually it's
actually one of my favorite songs and um
that was actually one of our first of
the Season yeah was it oh yeah I forgot
about that sorry we do so many songs oh
yeah thanks Alex yeah it's um you know
we're looking at doing a song it's like
do you stay true to the original do you
um slow it down what do you do that song
had such an emotion I thought it'd be
really cool to just slow it down and let
it be about Kelly's voice and so we did
it with just Jocko and I and um yeah
that's what I'm talking about yeah you
know it was like just acoustic and
pianos so let's let's take a look at it
it was a cool
um uh
actually I tried some this is actually
the first time now we're getting nerdy
and so producer Danny Andy is probably
not gonna want me to talk about this but
uh for all the music nerds out there
this is you know I'm playing this this
little grand piano and um here I'll just
pop it up on the screen there I think
it's up there now maybe
um thank you I can't see what we're
doing here but um so the grand piano I'm
playing has its own sounds that's
usually what you're hearing this time I
hooked up to my keyboard rig because I
wanted this kind of creepy sound going
behind it Kelly calls this swampy so
when Kelly says to do a song we usually
get a note to like make it more rock
make it more blues or make it more
swampy so I wanted to add a swampy sound
to this and so I hooked it up to my main
stage rig because that's the sound
you're in here anyway let's just play a
little bit
so the main stage is adding that Reverb
yeah that little sounds behind that's
lovely look at me studying my chart yeah
we're reading charts by the way because
we can't memorize all these songs right
there uh there's something wrong with
this I don't see me oh here let's go
ahead oh there's Jocko oh there I am
oh it's back to me thank you Joe our
great director knows where the great
music comes from I guess
but now we're talking over Caleb anyways
she just killed it I mean it's just a
beautiful
the thing that I love about this is
[Music]
I mean oh and I got to play 12th Street
yeah interesting fact I hate the 12
string come on yeah it's so it's so Out
Of Tune all the time it has this little
thing but you did great with it well I
didn't tune it Mark uh our extraordinary
guitar tech tuned it for me yeah well
it's that was fun to do it was a really
beautiful song and I hope we hope we get
it justice uh interesting things that
song was actually recorded at um a
studio it's the same Studio that we
recorded Never Enough for the greatest
showman soundtrack no way yeah and uh
it's now called East West Studios and
what was it called before
United Western and East West about it
now beautiful I think Pet Sounds was
recorded there in the same room we did
um so yeah cool little connection to
that one right there I think there's a
great doc about The Mamas and Papas it
might be like a VH1 one but I I watched
it on YouTube and
their story is wild everyone should
watch it
what was what was another song uh well
we did it was good uh wait we've done a
couple we did was that we found love or
we did oh uh We Found Love was like how
you did it on the road but umbrella oh
yeah umbrella was a brand new one oh
yeah okay so
um
Umbrella by Rihanna that was great
um so sometimes we completely reimagine
the song and sometimes we want to stay
true to the artists and sometimes we
take inspiration from their life so I
remember we were in rehearsal when we
pulled up the live version of umbrella
yeah and there was this actually there's
this cool riff it's like that
and I love a good theme so like I tried
to work it in every four bars Lester and
Kyle shut that down they were like
you're overdoing it and I'm like well
I'm the music director and they just
didn't play it and then I was recording
my extra guitar tracks because
it's revealed I record extra guitars and
uh I layered that lick as much as I
could so whenever yeah whenever you
whenever you listen to the song
um you actually hear Jocko and I play in
the Riff all the time unless they're not
so much but let's check it out
oh I did something wrong we're having a
technical difficulty here we go
[Applause]
it's a great classic drum rip there
[Music]
my hair is looking good on that I hear
that riff again
[Applause]
[Music]
shout out to Robert he's the mixer and
this mixer ducking awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
I also just like to shout out to my
childhood guitar that's what I'm playing
on this it uh my dad gave it to me when
I was like
five or six years old and then I had
Mark rework it the guitar tech and bring
it to life for modern era
that's cool yeah I mean you don't seem
that excited well it's a guitar they all
sound the same right guitar it's what I
learned that's so sweet I was a huge
Incubus fan and I even had them sign it
when I met them
Emily do we have any more questions
um from the audience
have a nice margarita
oh
really Incubus no yes
to Barbra Streisand no
wait I only like one bit have we ever
done a meatloaf
we should do meatloaf rest in peace
but those are one of those things like
how do you condense a meatloaf rock
opera down to a minute and a half
oh so the executive producer of The
Kelly Clarkson show just said that I can
do a four minute Kelly coming up soon
if it's meatloaf okay you heard it you
could probably carry down some meatloaf
if you cooked it under a brick right
what other questions do we have coming
in
wow Martin that's a that's Martin's a
smart guy is it pronounced Martin or
Martin
where is he from I need details can we
dial him up so for All You music nerds
we have a lot of software we use
um Robert records into Pro Tools Lester
loves Pro Tools yeah I don't yeah
chocolate and our logic guys so logic
pro that's why you're my Jeep that's
where it's at yeah so why do you like
logic so I'll be honest for all the
Nerds out there I started in logic when
it was e-magic oh I did too it's like 12
years old or something and and uh that's
just what I learned on it was the the
coolest thing ever my dad's a musician
and and he got a a Mac computer and it
was like Cutting Edge technology
oh Dandy Andy why don't you show us
logic I just want to show so this is
this is what logic looks like when we
record we have a track for for
everything we have you know here's kicks
snare hats Toms these are all the drums
guitars piano keys so this is what we
played a lot of tracks oh no well I mean
it's a lot of live playing no I mean
that's like like you have a mic for what
two mics on the kick drum uh what do we
have yeah we have a kick in a kick out
and a kick sub three mics on a kick drum
yeah that's pretty awesome
um
so logic's what I work in because it's
great to program and then we do we do
use tracks on the show and that doesn't
mean vocal tracks it means well why do
we use tracks I could tell you tell us
Jacob so when I play guitars
it just doesn't sound that good no
um when uh when you listen to a song
sometimes there's an acoustic guitar and
an electric guitar so I might pre-record
an acoustic guitar and then play the
more fun guitar which might be solo
electric guitar live yep and we use it
like we use it to fill in all the I mean
I'm gonna we're gonna get to break down
a song so I can play you the song what
it sounds like with just us playing and
what it's going to sound like with all
the extra pieces that that end up in
there I I have only two hands believe it
or not and so I can about 11 fingers
right no so all I can I can play piano
and I can play a B3 and when you watch
the show if you hear generally if you
hear a sound that's not a piano or an
organ you're actually hearing Rachel
play so Rachel does a lot of our drum
programming electronic Loops all of our
keyboard sounds and and it just adds so
much and fills it out and we're going to
get to get into that a little bit
but even if there's a lot of songs where
we have no tracks but we still play with
a click track the reason we do that is
because all the video all the lighting
you see everything that Darren Langer
brings to the table it's all being sunk
by something called simty it's simply is
a code that's running so all the lights
can time with every one of our hits and
everything that goes and it's pretty is
that Darren out there Darren's here Emmy
award-winning Darren Langer is here
I'd like I'd like to take a brief break
does everybody have cups should we pass
some
oh no I'm not I'm not being heard
choco I'm not talking loud enough one
thing that I've never heard anyone ever
tell me I'm gonna turn Jocko up a little
bit that's just not I'm gonna stand up
here and pour everyone in Negroni I told
you to put the microphone closer on the
other side but Jocko didn't listen to me
which is just like band rehearsals and
karaoke performances all right okay it's
time because how long have we got oh wow
we're gonna pass the Negroni round to
everyone wait a second what's this
wooden ball I just want to do something
real quick
um I hope you guys are enjoying this and
if you have any questions write them
down below like share subscribe I don't
trust our producers to ever I mean and
hello hey babe
hey I just know you would tell me the
truth are we doing a good job here are
you having fun
yeah you guys are doing great
to the one that told Rachel I knew it uh
Rhonda says you have to be closer to the
phone Ronda I heard from a little bird
that it might be your b day tomorrow
yeah did you know Rhonda that you share
a birthday with Andrea Jaco's girlfriend
Andrea and my wife Rhonda have the same
birthday does anybody have my phone yeah
can somebody Rachel do you have Andrea's
phone number
you know what we'll call her after this
reveal thanks thanks for being truthful
and text me if there's anything happy
birthday Rhonda
[Music]
oh we're sharing arlisha is deep in
Darren just got some Rachel's doing good
and we're having a great time
all right love you so wait Rhonda you
couldn't hear me
now okay all right we love you bye
just in my defense we did a tech
rehearsal and I was so loud yeah I know
he is and I'm usually so quiet I don't
think that producer Dandy Andy thought
that I would actually have any energy
but here it is all right let's do it
this is the whole reason we're doing
this
it's time to break down our favorite
karaoke of the week
can you guess what it is can I give some
hints please give some hints okay
It Was Written in 1995. do you know what
it is uh
get on Google look up songs that are
written in 1995.
okay I'll give you another hint the
singer was from Scotland
do you have a Shrek impression no no
does anybody no that's very insensitive
okay really yeah standards and practice
is Shrek not from Scotland you can't do
Shrek impersonations okay [ __ ] but ogres
are like onions okay the drummer for
this band produced one of the best
records of all time
Nirvana never mind yes so without
further Ado our deep dive this week is
four and it says music sting and we're
the band we actually don't have his
things so
ready this is uh
all right help me
all right guys this is one of the
coolest songs we've been able to do on
the show this is a little bit of Only
Happy When It Rains by garbage
[Music]
it's one of the swampy intros we wanted
watch the video on YouTube if you want
to see it oh
I just want to say that special thank
you
um we talked briefly about licensing and
um when when Andy is gone we can talk
more about all this stuff and all the
boring stuff
um send us comments follow Jocko and I
on Instagram and we'll we'll answer all
your direct messages about what it takes
to do this but Shirley Manson personally
cleared the songs garbage is not known
for letting people cover their songs on
television why'd you clear it uh I'm
assuming it's an interesting thing we've
actually Alex knows this we've there's
artists we've gone after from season one
that we were denied seeing like one
season two and now we're getting more
clearances and I think it's because
people actually trust Kelly is going to
do an amazing job with their song I mean
it's Kelly Clarkson she's a world class
so I know that you know that so but you
know nobody says Kelly Clarkson man
she's not that good I mean there's some
people just don't want anybody to cover
their babies yes so thank you Shirley
for making this happen thank you Shirley
I actually saw garbage back in London
probably 15 28 something years no way
and they had they had Butch Vig in a
drum cage
and it was controversial Army Lee style
it was controversial at the time but
it's because their sound is amazing like
the way you mean like a like a fishbowl
like uh like for people to go to church
like sometimes they put the Church
drummers and like Behind These like
plexigas yeah Plexiglas and and what it
does is it isolates the drum sound for
the mixer so that the mixer doesn't get
the drums in the vocal mic right yep and
so it just helps with all the sound so
um and guys if we're boring you just put
in the comments boring boring boring and
we'll move on but this is the part I'm
actually the most excited about so M
Night Margarita are we losing followers
all right well producer Dandy Andy just
slow me down if we're going too deep
into this but this song The reason I
chose it has it all it has
um it has the Kelly it has a different
take on it yep and a lot of times I like
to have our different take and then I
like to just pop it and go wow yep it
has the Kelly jumping the octave which
um sorry Kelly you messed yourself up
when you wrote since you've been gone it
was it was her idea to jump the octave
and now everybody loves that and so
anytime we can work that in and I'll
show you where that happens it has
tracks broken by Rachel and I'm going to
tell you a little bit about what it
sounds like with and without it so you
can see what it adds and um and we're
gonna we're gonna show you some things
that I don't think anybody's ever seen
before on I mean we're literally
um NBC is kindly allowing us to like
literally open the vault and show some
Secrets isn't that nice of NBC thank you
so much once again if we do good we can
keep doing this a lot or all right
they're telling me to move on okay yeah
so let's let's take a look at this
should we talk about that lighting glow
on Kelly's hair it is beautiful it's
nice
you're great
oh did you see that guitar pose I did on
that first one
okay now this is I find this interesting
one more time let's just let's listen to
Kelly's tender emotional voice here
we're all gonna pause and we're gonna
soak in just the voice and I won't talk
over it right and I'm going somewhere
with this yeah I believe just trust me
Andy here we go
oh it's so beautiful
[Music]
okay so you're hearing the emotion of
her voice I want to play you what
Kelly's actually Hearing in her ears
right now oh no we we talked we talked
about our click track and um and this is
so that lighting can be in perfect sink
now sometimes lighting I don't get them
what they need in time and so they're
doing it on the Fly and they're doing a
great job with it but the whole time
Kelly is trying to emote and connect
with the lyrics a she hears my annoying
voice count off three four it haunts me
in my dreams so we'll talk about that on
another episode just very quick Jason
counts off everything for us in our ears
and he likes to go three four and then
stop it I'm just testing things all
right so here's what here's what Kelly
here so listen you can hear my voice
you'll hear the click track keeping
ocean Tempo here three four five
so she's trying to emote with this
annoying
She lays back amazing against the click
too and now notice here we're about to
take it out of Swampy into the garbage
version You're Gonna Hear It speed up
and I'm gonna have to cure her again
here we go
[Music]
so Alex has always wondered so we're on
stage and Kelly says oh that was the
wrong count because sometimes I give her
the wrong count and I'm sometimes I'm
like one two instruments anyway that's
what Kelly's hearing right now I've
actually never heard that before and
that would be really hard click click
three four I'm only happy with it it's
just doing this the whole time when
you're trying to be that's really
impressive let's just a little bit of
this chorus here I want to show you some
things
I'm Only Happy When It Rains so right
now you're hearing the full mix that
Robert Venable put out sounds awesome
[Music]
feeling it well you look like you're
feeling it let's hear what Jocko's
actually oh no
so here's Jocko did I do it
[Music]
all right let's put Kelly back in let's
put Kelly yeah here's just make this a
Kelly Jacob just Kelly and Jacob praise
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right all right so I wanna
I wanna brag on on Rachel Oh I thought
do you want to just brag on my guitar
post for one sec look at that freeze
frame I can't see the freeze frame but
it's uh now looking at the freeze turn
around let me show you my Freeze Frame
now Jason
all right cool so here is what Rachel
does and so this is all of Rachel's
Ambience at the beginning she created
what the swampy she's a swamp expert now
this is just Rachel this is my guitar
swamping
isn't that beautiful now let's hear just
Rachel and Kelly together
wow that's cool
[Music]
why did we have any of the band play
this is even more pretty I think the
cool version now let's go good job
Rachel let's hear what Lester is up that
sounds awesome
all right here's just the drums
[Music]
and on top of the drums Rachel also does
our drum programming so here's Rachel
here
oh the floor up
wait so what's the drum programming
here's Rachel
all that stuff oh so she's like
tambourine and that level
thing
all right that's awesome all right now
if you want to hear a master class and
vocal we've we've we've given Kelly to
full range now she started off slow and
intimate we're keeping her subdued and
um angsty and this is my favorite part
when she jumps up this is something a
lot of people haven't heard this is what
this is literally the Raw
the raw audio from her vocal yeah you
can hear the drums bleeding the
background but this is this is it here
we go we're gonna we're gonna jump up
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you better sing Cali
yeah I want to hear that one more time
[Music]
that's so cool so so like if Jocko
couldn't make the show for some reason
or another this is what we would sound
like let's see I'm just curious are you
muting my tracks are leaving them in I'm
just going to take you out so this is
see that's the thing he's taking me out
yeah so this is this is Kelly and the
band minus just turned into a mafia show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it's actually kind of whacked without
me
here's my organ I'm playing
oh yeah I uh if I may just toot you a
little I just tooted
Jason happens to be one of the best
organ players of all time and we sit in
rehearsals and yeah you can play piano
guys
yeah we can't have that
all right let's go back to thank you
chocolate you're a great guitar player
all I'm saying is that Jason is great
oh no
so Jason
did that episode air with the accordion
yeah that was actually Lady Lady
Marmalade oh [ __ ] where's the marmalade
lady marmal lady
marmal you just got your third strike
with NBC standards and practices and
they're now in the doorway [ __ ] I said
[ __ ]
and they're pulling the plug all right
that deserves a Jocko time out and I'm
gonna and I'm gonna mute his microphone
okay so we're gonna leave Jack on time
alphabet so Lady Marmalade was great
because we wanted that song has been
done so many times by so many amazing
vocalists that Kelly wanted a totally
different vibe and so we
we slowed it down and I apologize to all
the real accordion players out there
anybody that knows I'm a cheating
according player I can't play my left
hand I don't know there's like there's
like 100 buttons there that I don't know
what they do so I just play with the
right hand here and producer Danny Andy
says take Jocko out of jail
now okay now you're back
uh Emily save us do we have any more
fans was that I mean and we can go back
into more of that stuff but this this is
giving a taste of the type of things
that we're allowed to do now yeah it's
like a test run yeah and if you like it
we can go deeper into some things the
cool stuff like the stuff that I'm doing
and we're doing like that yeah let us
know what you like or we can do the
boring stuff but anyway audience
questions please what do we have Emily
M nights margarita
question
oh I know Jason Loves Country no I'm I
love 80s anytime I can't wait to Deep
dive into some 80s songs which we're
gonna have coming up Jaco's Mr 90s yep
so when we get to
Third Eye Blind Spin Doctors it is a
dream come true
wait there was a country song that you
sang every word to oh yeah what was it
my favorite country song was maybe it
was Memphis Pam Tillis and you you had a
story about it you ever saw a dance or
something when you were a kid yeah one
of my first concerts was George Strait
and Pam Tillis so yes I know everywhere
that's why Kelly my uh sorry my karaoke
song or Alex has a question executive
producer
hey Carl
that that was so so Carl said with
Dancing Queen what was the inspiration
to make it so unique right yeah that
that was 100 Kelly so usually
um you know whenever I I send Kelly a
list of all the songs that are coming up
down down the pipe and I'd say about
20 30 of them she has specific things
that she wants done with that and that
one she really wanted to it never
occurred to I never would have thought
to slow that song down and make it an
intimate song and it was like it was
emotional it was like a really beautiful
thing to do like it's um and a lot of
times dude that okay so that that
particular time that was Kelly purposely
giving that direction a funny thing that
happens with the band is sometimes when
you hear a slowed down song that you're
like wow they reimagined that isn't that
amazing what happens is we've actually
rehearsed a full rock version of a song
Darren's programmed all these beautiful
lights and we're going full out
but we haven't performed this song in
two weeks so we're trying to remember it
so Kelly gets on stage after and then
literally I'm just trying to remember
the parts I might start playing the
piano with Jocko plays the guitar Kelly
hears that and she's like oh we should
do that just piano only or oh that
should be a guitar we try to duck with
Jason a lot because he'll give Kelly
some guide on piano and we go
this one's gonna be piano only
and I don't know 20 of the time that
does happen so a lot of times it's
purposeful sometimes it's it's
accidental we had one recently uh Alibis
it was that was the country song yeah
yeah Alibis Jocko couldn't remember the
part no I can remember the part Jesse
said Jesse said what are the chords or
something like that so I start playing
it and then Kelly was hearing it in her
ears and she goes oh my gosh that's like
that's so emotional it's sad whatever
and let's do it just a guitar for the
first Verse Chorus and I was like well
maybe the band could come in at some
point in the thing so we did it Jason
and then sometimes our reimaginations
are just
I'm not familiar I mean we all have our
our strong suits and some songs I'm just
not familiar with so I think I'm nailing
it just like the original and then I get
this feedback like wow what an
interesting interpretation of that song
what did I miss it looked like you were
having fun
Emily any more questions margarita
are there ever not last second changes
so the question was is there any last
minute uh adjustments or changes and and
the short answer is yes yeah
um you know the so when Jocko plays a
guitar if he hits this string this note
it makes the same tone every single time
hey you don't know my tones yeah when I
play the piano
it's always the same note the human
voice it could vary by the weather by
your emotional state by you know
anything so many variations there's so
many variations and so a lot of times
last minute we have to take a song up a
step down a step somewhere in between
which can be really hard sometimes we
cut a bridge cut a second chord like
sometimes we'll do a double chorus and
we cut it in half yeah and it just
depends on the mood and the tone of that
day so there's there's many times last
minute changes and then and then
sometimes there's just so much going on
that I haven't looked ahead and I've
forgotten about a song and then we have
to rehearse it last minute sometimes
there's last minute changes in that
we're supposed to play a song and then
we play a different song yep yep that we
haven't rehearsed yeah so it all comes
up reimagined very well I actually
really enjoy it uh keeps me quick on my
head foot as you would say I don't know
as I would say Okay Emily quick on my
feet but with my brain head foot
uh um I'm gonna add to the the requests
list in addition to the four minute
meatloaf people are really curious why
are you yelling
that's my fault I'm sorry I actually I
started off the season I forgot about
Kelly lee Classics who invented the
karaoke sorry she was asking what about
Kelly what about karaoke classics and we
actually do have a few coming up we've
actually rehearsed two karaoke classics
um that we've swapped out last minute
for last minute changes because we were
feeling a different type of song or
um the other thing that happens too is
I'm I'm I'm slotting out our karaoke's
for the next three or four weeks and
then information is coming into me about
a guest that's coming on and so I'm
having to move things around because
some songs might be better for certain
guests than other guests so we've moved
a couple of Kelly lucky classics there's
a lot of love from my December
um I'm thinking that's what Emily's
saying and so
yeah have we not done any my December
karaoke classics yes
this is my December and never again was
on my December and that was actually one
of some fan out there thank you um gave
us the idea on Twitter to do that piano
only and it was great and Jocko loved it
because he got a break on stage every
night to go refill one of my first tours
actually with you you had a you would do
a full medley it was great oh oh I love
a good medley but it's piano only
well I would love to play more garbage
stuff but maybe there's more questions
oh
Sam Smith The Rock will want to know who
takes those songs is it Kelly is the
guest
we love for sorry um so Emily is
somebody's asking how do Duets come
together who picks a song does Kelly
picked the song does the duet artist
pick the song We Love in the Kelly
Clarkson show for the guests to pick the
song did The Rock pick that song he did
actually yeah fun fact I think actually
tell this we had actually rehearsed
um so Dwayne Johnson bye Rachel thank
you for all you do have a great
Thanksgiving
um so Dwayne Johnson he Alex right he
works out too it's raining men that's
one of his favorite songs wait wait can
we just take one step back did you just
say that Dwayne Johnson works out to
It's Raining Men yes Dwayne Johnson
works out too it's raining man
It's Raining Men
Hallelujah yes no he doesn't he really
does so that's why we that's why we
chose that song because we wanted to
surprise him with Kelly singing one of
his favorite songs that gets him pumped
up Dwayne if you're watching give me a
call let's talk about this it's a great
pump up song you're like pump up song
It's Raining Men I'm about to put you in
timeout again okay uh
so we actually rehearsed It's Raining
Men right and we had it all prepared to
go it was the night the day before uh
the legend of Loretta Lynn passed away
uh and so uh Dwayne then uh because he
he used to be an aspiring country singer
back and I was I didn't know that until
the show that makes sense then yeah and
so he actually requested that they do
that song as a duet and remember we
learned it the day before during lunch
when we're usually at Karo Soul
um having negronis and various drinks
next door
um yes
no the whole band goes it's awesome
um and we talk about Kelly Cookies all
day because that's our whole life
um yeah so we chose that last minute we
picked it last minute and that's an
example of the artist choosing it
um that was a great episode because also
there was the fire dancer oh and Jason
and I we got you oh yeah that's all my
socials that was so much fun that's that
was the best oh that's airs tomorrow uh
it airs again tomorrow
that's my favorite part about being a
show like Kelly who's a cool everything
but like all those little neat things
like we have some amazing stuff coming
up I gotta say Dwayne is a stand-up guy
too yeah we have lots of guests and
they're all great but Dwayne came over
shook all her hands and was like we're
gonna perform together I hope I don't
suck whatever and he did an awesome job
and he came in he looks so strong nailed
a song Handsome that Sam Smith duet was
great that was a very difficult one to
arrange um because uh Sam is a very high
singer for
um
for for his for their vocal range and
Kelly's we've been doing Breakaway for
almost 20 years now and so it's actually
harder sometimes to perform a song that
you have done so much Sam's vocal was so
great though right yep yeah he just they
just like Blended perfectly with Kelly
yeah it was it was awesome uh we have
one of the we have an excitement was
also surprisingly tall yes yep I'm six
one
[Music]
I'm looking at Sam
and they was like way up there yeah just
like just like their voice yeah so we
have an exciting duet coming up
um it's one of the biggest Legends of
all time and uh NBC's looking at me now
I'm out to say who it is yeah yeah it's
okay yeah we have the legendary Dolly
Parton
and we're doing a duet with Dolly and
Kelly it's gonna end as long as you know
I got to record Kelly's uh Kelly and
Dolly's duet of nine to five the
reimagined version uh and it's so cool
so it's a very chill thing but then
selfishly when I heard dollars I mean
who doesn't want to play the OG nine to
five so we've we've found a way to blend
the Two Worlds together and it's I
actually can't even remember a lot of
that day I'm glad it's not I mean Dolly
came over to the band and was just so
she she just put us at ease she actually
told Jocko she gave Jocko permission to
mess permission to mess up yeah and then
I revoked that permission I said he's
not gonna mess up dolly is is one of a
kind and and a true charmer like she
she's not phased and she's like I've
I've been doing this forever and y'all
are awesome this is great and her vocal
was just spot on we actually so that's
what's coming up I know uh Ozzy Osborne
Dr Ozzy Andy is telling us to wrap up
but we actually played last year at the
is was it the CMAs or the acms one of
the country ones yeah we performed I'll
always love you in front of Dolly which
that was probably one of the most
terrifying moments of my entire life it
started and then went to Jason and I'm
going wait so Dolly's just gonna watch
us watch us do I will always love you
and um
whatever
um but it was great and and Dolly said
we did a great job and it was really
cool I did that once with Miley we
played
um 50 ways to lose your lover Paul Simon
in front of Paul Simon it was the SNL
50th anniversary and then afterwards
like shake his hand and go
okay well dude I'm so glad we did this
and thank you everybody I'm glad I think
it's gonna be fun well it's gonna go
we're gonna find out a fun time I'm just
kidding so so if this was great
everybody
um leave the comments if we want to do
this again so if there's something else
you want to hear if you want to hear
um more specific information or you you
tell us we want to do this and so we're
we'll give you each other like our phone
numbers you can call us at any time
we'll hang out let's meet up it's all
good leave your questions for us in the
comments uh we have some amazing stuff
coming up soon and I would just love to
nerd out with you guys and talk more
about it can I be sentimental for one
second
Happy Thanksgiving to everyone out there
Happy Thanksgiving to you I hope you
have a wonderful turkey day well thank
you choco and uh I would also like to
wish a special happy birthday
to my wife and Joker my girlfriend
Andrea Sheriff turns out oddly enough
we
dates or are married to people that were
born on the same day which says
something weird about us
[Laughter]
all right guys well thank you so much so
or did we go okay Alex are you happy oh
thank you cheers to you thanks for
making this happen cheers to y'all and
thanks to Jenny for letting this happen
for being here
all right let's listen to Jocko and I
sing some more do the theme song no here
it comes ready put the theme song on see
you guys soon
[Music]
in a while
foreign
[Music]
[Music]